hello went welcome to this video playing
maradona one of the frequent opponents
IE case the king's indian guy let's see
if i can play a better better age 3 line
this time yeah there should be two this
is how i just played nowadays 95 losing
stuff that's not working I think it's
played like that right back at Bishop g5
if i'm not mistaken and queen you too
and castles long
you
hmm 94 night might come to you for but
still I still I think two should be
right Bishop age 6 i'd like to trade off
that that that bishop even though it's
got 90 form and maybe you can go bishop
age 694 text eggs couldn't see one at
some f for business hmmm maybe but hard
now not to not to do that to be honest
Queenie three or so to see 123 this f4 I
guess okay let's go back yeah I've seen
it coming have seen it coming
I really have to have to learn that
opening better this is this is not
acceptable
that's a second terrible position in a
row from this from this line
I need to cancel badly okay I mean of
course he can do that i was thinking
queen d 4 but this is Jack really a big
deal even 25 is a move
yeah that night on edge form it's not a
great piece it really isn't I'm okay
with her taking now I mean you cannot so
easily attack it that's that's the only
thing in my favor all that let's say
that makes this position at least
somewhat viable at least I hope it is
somewhat viable can I like look hero3
make you might even just take h 30 k is
shooting for Luke to h6
Jack here let's put this put this on f5
I can actually now have to do this for
bishops III I can get you for with my
bishop then things are not so bad
huh yes that doesn't it isn't so bad it
really isn't
f3 this age form ok no I don't want to
do I want to give up that so I'm
probably this ok
if you need is six is some kind of move
back time morning would love to have a
little bit more time here
hmm c6 coming next
the loops is seven know and just gives
me stuff okay black resigns I don't
understand anything about that game that
to be perfectly honest I don't
understand anything yeah i mean i
understand that i was again doing badly
in the opening probably 22 is already
bad i'm now absolutely have to learn
that opening better maybe quincy too i
don't know the other ideas this is bad
why go back to you three now maybe well
this is this is just not good no i
really had a good good position now
check check yeah here black isn't in
very good shape my night on h4 looks
some quite quite ridiculous the engine
is I mean it just gives 0.54 black I
mean not like a complete win but it
feels very bad route d8 it looks normal
yeah and now I'm in trouble with that
night so I decided to just enter them
and he he took it the computer wants to
do this now that this can quite a good
move at controls the g file
and now Knight f3 this Bishop see to
this is really not not that great here
by Bishop now has transformed into a
really good piece yeah here this is
already already already around equal he
probably had a good position again but
this should be for that was bad you turn
did you get form okay oh yeah because
this and this is a pretty awkward fork
now now that was that was the thing and
what the engine is giving is I should do
this first and then played should be
formed so that after this I can now play
this move for the deep pond with equal
play it seems very complicated stuff
yeah so look f4 was missed but now I'm
getting getting some somehow into the
game a little bit and this is probably
wrong I don't know antique stakes is
given by the computers minus 1 M it was
a pretty pretty lucky game anyway yeah
this I don't know and now now he has to
go books is Sapna this is just not
working at all and Roxy seven and six Y
and well there's rooty seven assists
this is an idea of it it's not like a
promotion immediately shine like this he
has this and the situation is not
totally clear but black is better yeah
this is this is handing me the game yeah
I don't know somehow seems that he lost
his nerve there or anything or
overlooked something something simple
still a pretty shaky game I definitely
have to look at this opening far more
closely okay thanks for watching